le truc de monsieur spock portait
première baffe jeune très jeune j'ai
passé une baffe ou une droite si c'était
une base c'est peut-être vos parents
c'était une droite s'était pas vos
parents ou mon frère ouais mon premier
désir première fois que vous avez
éprouver du désir pour quelqu'un ou une
paire de baskets sur moi à oui premier
amour mais je le cherche encore à quai
ici alors on a fait ce qu'il faut savoir
il ya l'euphorie quand même l'arbre peut
guère faire plus
aussi monsieur cayla qui est super mais
il faut aller habiter dans le larzac en
même temps un premier organe cherche
encore la paire de baskets et la paire
de baskets premier tax vous étiez
tagueurs avant ouais alors de faire la
rue blanche très très tôt ouais bon la
plage proche et pas de 14 ans et vitakic
ou alors c'est très compliqué mais on
taillait beaucoup mais je suis bien des
choses c'était des dessins c'était des
prêts à commencer par le tag pur et dur
et puis après c'est parti vers la
peinture plus plu soit les fresques et
c'est ce qu'on appelle le graphe et
grafite et purs et durs et maintenant
premier cachet d'aspirine supprimerait
proches premier voyage au maroc voir la
famille quand on était petits première
cuite
paris perd tarde d'arriver de l'apple
vaut pas vraiment la joie du vin est ce
que vous êtes un musulman est ce que
vous êtes musulman pratiquant musulman
mais aussi parce qu'on a eues ici djamel
bouras ont été très étonné parce que là
aussi c'est un truc était très souvent
été très étonné c'est un musulman qui
revendiquait sa religion jeune moderne
turakie revendiquer sa religion la
télévision et on s'est aperçu en
écoutant djamel bouras que finalement
une c'était très rare aussi ça faisait
des cathos qui viennent juifs qui
viennent pas de la religion mais
musulman
on était très sonné vous vous êtes
musulman pratiquement vêtements
musulmans pratiquants de père de mère
est de tradition que vous faites comme
nous avec le préservatif si vous buvez
un petit couteau
ouais 1er juin n'ont pas toujours pas de
juin nous a parlé vacances fin juin la
première ligne rerb olona gardienne là
on va lui-même serge josé parure a voulu
s'épiler merci d'être venu dans lequel